the other thing about good dialogue is
that it beats around the bush nobody
ever comes right out and says something
instead what they do is they hint it
things and so that ends up being subtext
and subtext is dialogue plus action it's
never only the dialogue usually style
like + action so if I am sitting in the
cinema seat and there is a and ice then
my line of dialogue is can I sit here is
it okay if I sit here that line of
dialogue changes meanings if it's a
gigantic huge you know ex-convict with
tattoos all over them or if it's an
attractive member of the opposite sex
but the same line of dialogue has two
different meanings there because of the
situation and one of the things we want
to do is again that's the dialogue is
not carrying the story there it's it's
part of the visual and the verbal is a
movie but characters often hint around
two things I never come right out and
say them and that's good dialogue -
because if you think about characters as
like I like to think about it's a first
date you're on a first date you aren't
going to immediately ask so you ever
been married you divorced instead what
you do is say well you know how do you
feel about you know something that's
that seems neutral and it's the neutral
way to get the information you ask
questions like you never asked so how do
you feel about equal rights and
responsibilities when really what you
want to ask is you just ordered this
lobster plate it's gonna max out my
credit card would you could this be
Dutch you know you sort of hint around
it things and that's how people really
talk or at least that's what seems real
on film is if characters don't come
right out and say things if they hint
around and that again comes with once
they hit around the audience either
knows or does not know what the reality
is and so we get either infirmity either
we're learning information from how they
respond to the hints or we already know
information that we're going they're
trying to hide this this information
hidden agenda talk hidden agenda talk
yeah so that ends up being you know and
a lot of
Minh agenda we all have our hidden
agendas no matter what it is if we're on
the first date our hidden agenda is
learning as much about that other person
as we can to figure out if there's going
to be a second date and so we're always
trying to feel out the situation by sort
of trying to find the neutral question
that gives us the information if
possible so we may not come up with a
direct question we'll find the indirect
way to find that information so that's
like a subtext element thing
you